[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
end game class
as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i am going to be walking you
through
some really fun end games involving
having a rook against not one but
two minor pieces now this is a really
interesting imbalance that most people
get well acquainted with
early on in their chess career thanks to
some early sacrifices on
f2 but maybe you shouldn't be doing it
uh
beginners just love giving up two minor
pieces on f2
against a castle king for that rook on
f1 won't get into that though because
that's not
the end game that happens earlier on but
let's look at the really interesting
imbalance as it happens in the end game
so let's just jump right into it here
i have from deep in my files deep deep
deep in my files
had to go underground for this one
searching through the stacks of chess
games i've played in my career
we have a game between the one the only
the child prodigy rochelle wu
uh who i believe made her debut in the
us women's champion
us june women u.s girls junior
championship this year
uh against myself and this is back in
2016 at a tournament here at the st
louis chess club
and at the time i really didn't know who
rochelle was or who she would go on to
be
but uh she gave me a really tough time
in
this game and i wanted to start actually
from the opening not spending too much
time because of course
we are focusing on the end game here but
it's worth taking a note to see how we
got there
we had a carol khan uh knight c3
the uh classical variation normal stuff
normal stuff normal stuff you know who
cares it's the opening go go go go go
uh and then uh got a little bit out of
theory
when rochelle played this interesting
move knight to e4
didn't really know what was going on
here doesn't really matter
for the most part though we see knight f
takes d4
and then i sort of lost my nerve here i
was worried about getting checked
getting checked is very very scary so i
tried to stop it with queen b4
this turned out to be wrong though and
rochelle gets a really nice position
thanks to some double attacks here i
have to go king f8
giving up my castling rights anyways
knight c4
really coming after the d6 square now
and
things go sort of from bad to worse
pretty quickly forming here you see 95
knight f6 and knight d6 is is the nasty
nasty idea
and believe it or not there's just no
way for me to defend this f7 pawn
this f7 pawn is is going down it's
attacked twice
by two knights of course you cannot take
the knight due to knight g6 check
so in the game i played you know the
rather sad move king to g8
see knight takes on f7 rook h7
and i would be hard-pressed to remember
a time when i had a worse position
out of the opening in the caro khan so
rochelle really uh
really hurting me here then rochelle
actually castles queenside
which is a bit of a mistake uh whenever
you go sort of fishing like this
with your your knight out two to f7 deep
in enemy territory
you should be working on an exit
strategy as well and that's something
rochelle
sort of neglected to do here so i
managed to find my way back into the
game
with the move rook f8 here when suddenly
this knight is entirely trapped
so we see uh rook d to e1 and then the
classic imbalance that i wanted to talk
about here tonight
with rook takes f7 knight takes seven
knight takes up seven and queen takes f7
so i have succeeded in taking
two knights for my one little lonely
rook
but the story does not necessarily end
there so i'd like you to think from
rochelle's perspective here
about how you would want to continue in
this position now it might not seem like
the end game yet
but we are sort of end game adjacent
here and i want to talk about some
decisions rochelle
made that made converting this end game
a lot harder for her
than it needed to be
so both a specific move here for white
and
sort of in general what white should be
trying to accomplish
in this position what do you guys think
yeah nice rook on h7 everybody loves the
rook on h7
so you guys have some pretty good ideas
here i really like the move some people
are suggesting which is the move uh
queen to b8 check
and black sort of has to play the move
98 to keep the pawn on b7 defended
and from there you can expect to see uh
white aiming to activate the rook uh
from h1
with rook h4 rook h3 and sort of
swinging it over
to uh to enter the game now this is
going to give black a lot of problems
because we still have to find
some way to activate the rook on h7
probably black is going to play rook h8
and king h7
and will probably be surviving for the
moment this rook is
eventually getting back into the game
although the wasted time of course
is going to allow white to continue to
activate and continue to make threats
now the important thing to note here is
that
with the queens on the board with a lot
of pieces
for black to worry about it's a lot more
difficult for black to activate this
rook and bring it into the game
now this is sort of along the right idea
white wants to keep the queens on the
board and continue
going after the king with the rook
against the minor pieces
now this is sort of counter-intuitive
because we're sort of told
that the minor pieces are good in the
middle game
and bad in the end game against the rook
but we'll see that that might not be the
case here
instead rochelle goes with queen e5 with
the very very simple idea of taking the
pawn on e6
and while this does maintain an edge for
white we'll see that this is a little
bit too
friendly uh towards towards me here
i of course play the move rook h8 i want
to get this rook back into the game
and rochelle just takes this extra pawn
but now
i think this was in fact a poor decision
for rochelle
to enter this end game where i have the
two knights against the rook
why was it a poor decision well because
it allows me a lot of
opportunity to activate all of my pieces
immediately
rather than the the slow slog slash
struggle i would have had with the queen
applying a lot of pressure
so sort of a poor decision by rochelle
to actually enter this end game
in my opinion now we continued here with
the move king
f7 that's what i played rochelle
continues with the very natural rook
h to e1 and now i have a question for
you chatroom
i have a question for you black to move
here
what should we do with this rook or
should we not do anything with this rook
black to move what do you guys think
what do you think
so yeah exquisite corpse points out that
white's advantage was because black was
inactive
and now if black activates it's a chess
game this is true
uh it's important noting though that
rochelle didn't get nothing
for the uh activity that she gave me she
did take this pawn on e6 and now has two
pawns
in the rook for the two nights so
it was a trade off by rochelle it wasn't
you know something for nothing
something for something but i don't
think it was quite enough for the
activity i lacked
and yeah everybody and myself we all
have the wrong answer
of course with rook to e8 rook t8 is a
bad move
it's a bad move i wish somebody would
have told me back
in 2016 not to play rook to e8 here
because it is
in fact pretty objectively just just
wrong
now i'm gonna tell you guys a secret
that i didn't know
until recently but when you have the two
pieces
against a rook you're oftentimes told
that
in the middle game they can be super
strong the two pieces
can fight very very well the rooks often
get tangled up in the middle game
because there's not enough open files
for them to shine
and the closer and closer you get to an
end game the more powerful the rook gets
because there's more open files the rook
can move about a bit more freely
and this idea is generally true but
usually it doesn't get more specific
than that in this case though
i'm going to tell you very specifically
almost
always almost always almost 100 of the
time
the two pieces are a lot better with a
single
extra rook on the board so two pieces
plus a rook
against two rooks is a lot a lot a lot
better
for the pieces than it is uh versus uh
just two pieces versus one rook right
and the reason for that
is sort of multi-fold here uh just like
the paper towels
so uh why is it that black would prefer
to have this extra rook on the board
well for one when you have two rooks on
the board they can often end up being
superfluous
that is serving the same job as each
other when really this
the job could have been done with just
one rook and that's sort of what we're
seeing here
right white has good control over the
e-file but really
white would still have good control over
the e file if this rook on e6 didn't
exist
so believe it or not the best move here
is actually the paradoxical
rook to b8 going for passivity allowing
something like rook to e7 check
and just playing with this position with
the passive rook even the super super
passive rook
uh is gonna be better for black than
playing with the knights alone
now just to prove it to you let's play a
few more moves let's say uh
well okay it's tough to not hang this h5
pawn but pretending white's not even
hanging this pawn let's play something
like f3
knight b to d5 rook e5 and
something like knight f4 and g4
now uh the knights have good control
over the position they've done
okay well i'm blundering here blundering
a bit
actually i'm just blundering everything
so let's say that all these tactics
don't even exist though like let's say
that i play b5 here we see g4
knight f4 king d2
uh the knights have good control over
the position
and they do very very well at hampering
the white rooks
from invading right they're sort of
keeping both rooks at bay
and in the meantime we sort of have this
extra rook here on b8
that black is a little bit more free to
play around with now
compare this position to a position that
you can imagine where the rook on e5 is
traded off for the rook on b8
now the knights are still keeping this
one rook at bay
but they're not really doing much more
right the knights aren't really enough
to make concrete threats on their own
and while they still keep the rook at
bay black doesn't really have this extra
piece to uh to move around with
so the point i'm trying to get out here
when possible
with the pieces you want to keep the
extra rook on the board
the reason for that is the two rooks for
whites are often superfluous
often serve the same job the knights can
sort of play against them
in the same way that they could against
one rook this gives black a little bit
more freedom
that they may need to to play around
with their own rook okay enough about
that though because
i wasn't the super genius chess player
that i am now in 2016 and of course i
plugged the natural move rook to e8
saying oh my god
these rooks are on the eve file it's
super scary let's trade those off
so really important principle to keep in
mind here
the two pieces work well with one rook
the rooks
would much prefer to have a soul rook
versus two piece end game
compared to two rooks versus two pieces
in a rook in the end game
okay enough about that though we see
rook takes the eight
knight takes e8 and g4 by rochelle
shoring up the the king's side
weaknesses now knight f6
by me just activating the knight and we
see the move
f3 so what's your guys's feeling
of this end game here we have two extra
pawns
for whites and the rook against the two
minor pieces the two knights
for black so what do you guys think uh
does white have good winning chances
does black have winning chances
is it equal what is
sort of the nature of this position here
elvis feels that white is better manny
says drawn
okay while you guys are thinking about
this though i will answer a couple of
the specific questions so maybe i didn't
do a great job of explaining the threats
here if you play a move like rick to d8
then this is simply a fork
and knight c to d5 isn't enough to stop
it because
uh this is coming anyways after c4 so
that's why we're up to b8 but anyways
enough about this is enough about the
specifics the point is the principle
you want the extra rook with uh with
black rick beat obviously isn't ideal
but it's sort of the only way to keep
the rook without blundering more
material
an anonymous person feels black as
winning manny says the pawns are very
powerful but black has the edge
with the two knights
anyone's game so it is definitely
white with the advantage here now uh
in the middle game two pawns in the rook
for the two pieces
can sort of be seen as a little bit more
of a fair trade but
as i said the principle goes the closer
and closer you get to a pure end game
the more and more powerful the rook gets
as opposed to the pieces now and here
the rook is in fact very very powerful
compared to the knights
the knights are a little bit awkward at
sort of creating threats
against white's structure like if if you
just think broadly
how is black ever going to try to win
the game you are going to be
hard-pressed to to come up with an
answer
to win the game you sort of have to make
a past pawn right
now structurally black just can't make a
past pawn so black has to win pawns in
order to make a past pawn right we
somehow have to
take the pawn on f3 off the board uh and
then take the pawn on g4 off the board
and then sort of go
g6 and like win right
but it turns out that this is just not
really a viable winning plan there's
just no way
for black to get after this pawn on f3
in the meantime let's try to come up
with a winning plan
for white what can white try to do to
win the game
and that is sort of the question of the
end game white is going to be better
with the extra pawns and the lack of
weaknesses in the structure
but can white actually win what is the
winning plan
and that's going to be the question that
we're hoping to solve here
as rochelle we're playing as rochelle
against me a little bit
different than normal yeah but uh it's a
little bit more interesting than black's
play i think
so uh in the game black plays the move
knight b
to d5 and as i've scrolled too far white
starts with the move c4 not spoiling too
much yet we see
knight f4 king d2 knight e6 and king up
to c3 just
defending all the pawns rather easily
now we have to move king to e7
okay so let's pause here and talk about
the winning plan
for white what should white try to do
here
to win this chess game how can we try to
win this chess game
what do you think chat room broadly not
specific moves yet
so everybody sort of has the the right
idea here you need
to create a past pawn and the way to do
that is to expand
yes on the queen slide and yes on the
king's side
so white's winning plan has to be to
break through
on either side of the board and create a
past
pawn now what this means for black is
that your
drawing idea is going to be to keep a
good grip on both
sides of the board at the same time
which can be rather difficult
when working with the knights being such
short range pieces
so i really actually do think rochelle
did a good job here
trying to press in the game with b4 this
is just a good start
to the position you don't actually have
to
figure out all the details from the
start you just want to start by
gaining a little bit of extra space as
rochelle does here i played king d6
and she plays a4 so far nothing has been
spoiled
now uh sensing that b5 might be coming
right if b5 here for example black is
happy to take
play knight d5 and completely take over
in front of this pawn
no no real problems here for black
so a4 is now sort of threatening
to go with something like this right and
taking over the d5 square as well with
some fluidity
in the structure for white if white
achieves something like this then i
think white is in fact
simply going to be winning the reason
being if black tries to do really
anything special
we can do a number of things let's just
defend first black passes
and eventually white i think is going to
break with d5
and just start invading here and these
pawns are a little bit too powerful a
protected pass pawn
is going to be quite strong here for
white and
let's not forget while white is gaining
all the space we can still create
threats over here
and create threats of f4 and g5 if black
gets a little bit too comfortable so
threats everywhere on the board
the knights aren't going to be able to
handle it so in
in an effort to stop this i play the
move a6
with black and here chat room i would
like you guys
to come up with another move for white
what should white
play in this position it's a actually
really really critical move here so
really critical move here
what should white do
what should white do in this position
and why
so a couple people have the the correct
answer so
chess king is actually suggesting what
rochelle did in the game
but it actually comes with a pretty
serious uh
mistake
so it's important to recognize black's
defensive ideas
along with our offensive ideas
so you guys are suggesting a lot of
great moves
for offense like rook to e5 just trying
to further our plan by controlling more
squares and activating our pieces
but black is actually creating a threat
with the move a6
and that threat is to play the move b5
with b5 we're going to see a lot of
simplifications
and we're going to see black taking
control of the really really
important d5 square if black is able to
control this square
then we're going to be able to blockade
pretty much
white's entire position by controlling
f4 from d5 by blockading the d pawn on
d4
and that's sort of the end of the story
right there's not much you can do
right so for example rookie 5 was played
in the game and this would have actually
allowed the move b5
and after some simplifications
for example something like this we have
the inner meso
knight d5 check king c4 would be a bit
of a mistake
because you can't actually go taking
this guy because of the d4 pawn
so king d3 or b3 for example
and black is able to take back on b5
blockade everything with the knights on
d5 and
the more you look at this position the
the less progress you're
actually going to make there's really
just no way no way through here
so b5 was the threat by black and the
correct way to stop
it is with a5 and after this it's going
to be a long and hard fight ahead
for black but i think this is really the
only way to continue pressing
for the win here with white and you have
to play a5 with the point being now b5
is running into a takes b6 with
uh well for the moment an extra pawn and
again activity down down the a
file right you need threats on both
sides of the board and
against b5 we have a takes b6 for that
so a5 really really important move here
never lose sight of your opponent's
defensive plans that could change the
structure
uh irreversibly and sort of throw away
all your winning chances
rookie five played in the game though
and me being a passer just plays the
move knight c7
no idea what i'm doing uh i think i was
worried about hanging upon
to uh uh just white capturing on b5
missing this knight
knight to d5 intermezzo so i played
knight to d7
knight to c7 now of course it should be
pretty clear what white's best move is
uh to the chat here of course white
should play a5 again
just preventing this idea of b5
but aside from a5 uh rochelle comes up
with another
really interesting idea here once again
the key for white has to be to make
threats on both sides of the board
to stretch black a little bit fit and
the way she goes about doing this
is with the move g5 uh still not really
giving me time for b5
uh i take on g5 of course we see rook
takes g5
and now despite giving herself a few
more weaknesses
on h5 and f3
rochelle has succeeded in creating
another target for herself
on the g7 pawn i continue now with
knight e6
we see rook to f5 and i continue just
passing the time
so white to move here chat room how
would you continue now
with white let's find the next active
plan
or uh or at least limiting plan
for uh for white here how do you want to
continue
rick g6 feels evil rook g6 might hang
upon right
might hang upon
all right we have three votes for d5
and he votes for any other pawn moves
one vote for b5
would have been pinned to the king i
disagree
i disagree right g6
knight takes here i have a knight here
you can't really do this
take it i don't know
all right we've got a couple votes for
b5 now a few votes for a5
one vote for c5 and yeah that's that's
sort of the question here
so these in my opinion are all
reasonable moves
c5 not the most reasonable move because
again the d5 square is just
sort of too important too important to
give up here so
d5 b5 and a5 all perfectly reasonable
moves now
uh the one that i sort of prefer the
most here with white
is in fact going to be the move a5 and
the reason for this
is that it sits on the position if you
play a move
like b5 or d5
you should calculate a lot you should
calculate a lot a lot a lot
before allowing the position to to
simplify
so if you play something like b5 here
yes it might immediately be good
but if you don't get something concrete
out of it the position
is going to tend toward a more simple
type of position
where black is able to consolidate a
little bit more easily now what do i
mean by that well we can actually see in
the game because rochelle did decide to
play
the move b5 so
b5 played in the game i played a takes
b5
ca takes b5 now knight c7
is a nice defensive idea the point being
we are still
not interested in playing something like
c takes b5
when white would again be gaining
control over really important squares
and being able to push two pawns
together
but instead uh forcing white to do
something with this pawn
or if white allows us to capture
forcing her to take back with the pawn
again giving us this nice little
uh blockade here on d5 uh perhaps
b6 first though would be quite relevant
to keep the king out
uh okay so knight c7 played in the game
and maybe this is something that
rochelle
hadn't either missed or not thought all
the way through because after b takes c6
b takes c6
king b4 she has tried to uh
as dvretsky would put it quote wyden the
beach head
white in the beach doveretsky loves that
phrase i don't know if anybody's read
fredski's endgame manual but this is
like his favorite phrase in the entire
world
widening the beachhead in a sense giving
the king a path
into the game uh but the expense of that
has come
at leaving herself with two pawns that
are going to be tough to keep track of
if your king goes goes exploring here on
the queen side
and black now doesn't really have any
weaknesses to keep track of
aside from the c6 pawn which is easily
defended by the king
so in her attempt to widen the beach
head perhaps she actually
narrowed the beach head because now all
black has to keep track of
is the c6 pawn whereas before there were
a lot more pawns
to try and keep track of so how should
white have continued again
i think this move a5 is actually
probably the best way to go about it
and is it enough to win i'm not so sure
but it does
for the moment keep the tension and it
allows black
some opportunities to to sort of mess up
we can play this position
kind of forever with white moving the
king back and forth
moving the rook back and forth um
creating threats over here
always hinting not playing a move like
b5 even a move like
d5 and yeah the game will continue
instead though we see b5 a takes b5 a
takes b5 knight c7
take on c6 take on c6 king b4 but
unfortunately after 96
the king has nothing better than to
return back to c3
and here we begin the great shuffle
rook a5 but nothing really doing
and black is just going to repeat
forever as i did in the game
and at the end of the day i miraculously
escaped with a draw now i think actually
uh the game went on a lot longer than
this
because uh uh
rochelle just kept like moving back and
forth not wanting to give me a draw i
think i actually claimed
threefold repetition uh amongst the king
shuffling back and forth
i don't even know if i claimed it
properly but rochelle sort of just
believed me
and had given up on the position i think
because there's really
nothing left to do for white here for
example
if you ever try to play the move d5
i'm simply going to capture it capture
it uh
go i think even just knight c7
and there's no good way to to save this
even knight takes d5 here is enough for
a draw
pretty easily i just come take this pawn
and that'll be the game
so nothing really left to do with white
and the game
was agreed to a draw by me claiming
three-fold repetition
at some point i think more moves were
played just shuffling back
and forth but nothing happened so
questions on this end game before i do a
brief review because
i thought there was some really
important stuff there was some really
important stuff to uh to go over here
was my reading this tournament i think i
was around 2000 and like 20
or something so still better than the
target audience of this class
but it was four years ago and i still
was not quite uh
quite as experienced in my carocon
going on twitch at 8pm central time
elvis so 25 more minutes top of the hour
at what point could white have forced a
win still well i'm not so sure that
white could have ever just
forced a win strictly and in the game in
the end game i would
say white's best opportunity was to play
the move a5
sort of at this juncture and sit on the
position a little bit more i think g5
was a good idea to try and create
threats on the king's side
but it did also saddle white with some
more weaknesses that weren't entirely
necessary
whereas a5 here just sort of does the
mean thing
and leaves black to his own devices
while she can
maneuver around as long as she desires
so i think this would have been the best
winning try in the end game definitely
earlier on though uh there were some
ideas missed here
i think probably white would have been
strictly winning with the clever move of
c4
in the opening because this is pretty
much the only way
to to get this knight evacuated out
through d6 for example rook f8
c5 and
the knight would be able to evacuate
not giving me this two pieces for rook
advantage that i got in the game so if
you want to say forced to win
maybe something like this would have
given white some really really good
chances
but as far as the end game i'm not
convinced it was ever entirely lost
all right so to recap what have we
learned from this
end game number one as far as the end
game goes
really really useful for the side with
the two pieces
to keep an extra rook on the board
lights rooks often end up being
superfluous
serving the same job as each other and
blackstrike can very often
move with a little bit more freedom as
the knights or a knight in a bishop even
can help hamper both rooks at the same
time
number two how do you win in these types
of end games
well you should attempt to create a past
pawn
and more directly create threats on both
sides of the board
trying to stretch the opponent's forces
then and then
finding a way to break through in this
case though
stout defense by caleb denby with the
two knights i was able to hold on to it
with that in mind let's move on to some
real chess players
such as one magnus carlsen so we're
gonna see
how magnus treated a similar end game
against one ivan chaparranov
so without further ado let's just jump
into it
nobody cares about this entire game
this is not the end game that i am
looking for
still not the end game i'm looking for
okay some more pieces coming off the
board now
all right i want to see i want to see
one more trade maybe
can we get one more trade magnus and
there you go and we have arrived
at our target end game so
what's going on here what's going on
here once again
we have two pieces in exchange for the
rook in this case though
white does have a knight in a bishop
rather than
two knights and again we actually see
black with
two extra pawns for this uh for this
imbalance of the rook versus the two
pieces so
what's the same and what's different
well of course the pawn structure is
different
the pieces themselves are slightly
different but
i'm still curious what you guys think
about the evaluation
of this position is magnus better as
rochelle was
against me or is magnus actually perhaps
on the worst side of things in this end
game what do you think
anawara says black is better bold claims
bold claims black slight advantage
because of the past pawn opportunities
black's better 50 50 d4 is strong
white is better so i tend to actually
favor the white pieces in this position
because a lot of things are drastically
different from
the last position that we looked at we
have the obvious differences that i sort
of listed out
but more subtly is something that
somebody in the chat actually brought up
although incorrectly uh
black actually doesn't have as many past
pawn
opportunities in this game compared to
what we were looking at in the last game
mainly because as many pointed out i
believe the pawn on d4
is quite strong and we have you know the
existence
of a dark squared bishops and bishops
control one color complex
very very well and the other color
complex not at all
in this case for white for black to make
a past pawn
uh you would have to break through on
one of these dark squares that the
bishop can help control so it's going to
be a difficult task ahead
for black to actually create a past pawn
number two
this pawn on c7 is very clearly
backwards and
it's not going to be easy to make it
sort of on backwards
and number three white's pieces have a
little
bit of activity they're well coordinated
and for the moment
black's rook is not exactly looking
the most active either so for the moment
i would actually rather have the white
pieces in this position that's not to
say black isn't without chances
as you can probably see by the result of
the game but uh
white is definitely well in it and let's
see what happens
first and foremost here we have king e8
rook d8 by magnus
now king e2 so magnus's next move is
pretty uh intuitive i think and also a
little bit instructive
so as the people in the chat were saying
and as i've mentioned
in the previous case oftentimes the only
way to try to win these kinds of
positions
is to make a past pawn so magnus starts
gearing up for this kind of idea
with the move f6 not necessarily looking
to play e5 immediately or even in the
near future
but number one hampering this knight not
allowing it to get to e5
and also introducing some ideas of
playing e5
in the future we see king d2
by chaparnov we see king f7 king c2
and now i would like you to guess
magnus carlsen's next few
moves here so you're playing with the
black pieces
um you're probably not necessarily any
better
at this point though i don't think white
can claim to be playing for a win
with the way black white has played the
last few moves just bringing the king to
the queen side
to guard the entry squares not exactly
you know a
stunning revelation that is playing for
the win
but uh how can you try and fight for
more as magnus here
maybe rook b8 only open file
so a lot of people say rook b8 york b
rook b8
rick h8 by faust
rook e8 and then e5 so a lot of good
ideas here
the idea i actually like the least is
the move rook to b8
so rook b8 i don't think is doing a very
good job
of fighting for the win now why not
well it's because white has actually
controlled the first
six squares on on the b file right
and due to the nature of having two
pieces against the rook
uh black is not really in a position to
play an exchange sacrifice if you know
what i mean
so you're never really making any
progress along the b file here so it's
better for the moment to leave the rook
a little bit more flexible
you might actually want to bring it to a
square like e8 or h8
but you don't really know which of those
squares you would prefer yet
so what magnus does over the next few
moves is an idea
some people have mentioned which is h5
magnus actually
is about to play h4 and h3 and this is a
great way
to apply some pressure to the opponent
it's very very similar
to the a5 idea that we took a look at in
the previous game
in this case though it's not even
necessarily a preventative measure
like a5 was preventing b5 in this case
magnus is just taking the extra space
and creating an opportunity for himself
to have not only a past pawn in the
future but a very very strong past
pawn so let's continue on here if white
were to try something
like h4 that allows magnus the
opportunity
to actually one create a past pawn on
the queen side
if white dares to capture on g5 or
to create an another open file another
much more useful open file
in the g file by taking on h4 and then
bringing the rook in
to to activity in this manner so
h4 not really a playable idea for white
instead white goes
bishop to a3 and then we see magnus
using again this leverage
to gain even more space we see g4
and now h3 by magnus so
really uh fun stuff by the world
champion already
without fear just launching the pawn
down the board using the fact that white
isn't really able to allow the opening
of more files
in order to create some weaknesses in
the white camp right you see how these
pawns are a little bit more disjointed
now
by creating these weaknesses in the
structure magnus gives himself
this little bit of play on both sides of
the board to use
the rook effectively now we see bishop
b2 by chaparranov
which again uh white is sort of now
playing playing without a plan white had
decided i think
pretty early on that's uh it was going
to be a defensive minded game
uh in the end game from white here
choosing not really to play for more
magnus now plays
some slower moves with king to e7 we see
knight c5
and actually rook a8 just as a defensive
measure
perhaps this bishop is coming to c3 to
put some pressure
we do see bishop to c3 and now
uh surprisingly magnus is quite willing
to give up this a5 pawn
with king to d6 this actually allows a
bit of a tactic here with bishop takes
a5 when rook takes a5
is unplayable due to the move of knight
b7 so perhaps i was actually being a
little bit too harsh on japan
his moves did have an idea the idea was
to come capture on
a5 so what's the downside to taking on
a5 well number one of course
magnus has managed to create weaknesses
over here
uh and number two by diverting the dark
square bishop
away from the center now is going to be
the opportune moment for magnus to start
breaking free
in the center of the board with the move
e5
we see white play bishop to b4 but
magnus has cleverly placed the pieces
so that the discoveries don't really
matter and we see e takes on d4
king d3 and king to c6
okay king takes d4 played in the game
and once again
it is magnus on the move here so we have
some pretty serious changes
to the position over the past few moves
magnus spent a lot of time playing h5 h4
h3 to provoke weaknesses on the king's
side
it's allowed white this opportunity to
come take off
the a5 pawn but now white has been
forced
to release the grip on the center in
exchange so was it all worth it
was it all worth it for black is black
still in the driver's seat here
or has something slipped how to continue
chat room
how to continue
so yeah everybody has has the right idea
here with rook to e8
the rook yes does thrive on open files
but again the difference here compared
to rook b8s
earlier is that magnus is actually
threatening
to invade this time we see the weak e2
square is now undefended
and it forces a concession by white to
play the move king d3 to defend it
whereas before rook b8 there were no
invasions no
invasion points so it didn't really have
a purpose
all right so we see the move rook e8
king d3 by whites
and now uh magnus does something uh
pretty cool uh he just plays the move g6
and says
all right your turn so i think a lot of
players myself included
would be a little bit nervous about the
prospect of allowing this a pawn
to run down the board but of course here
magnus realizes that giving up the b5
square is not
really something that white is allowed
to do just yet so
excuse me uh a5 not on the cards for
white just yet
which is why we see a little rerouting
of this knight
but this comes at the cost of allowing
the rook in
to e4 see knight d4 check king b6
f3 to defend and now rook back to e8
okay so white plays the move
knight to b3 now we see rook a8
by magnus which i'm going to level with
you
it's a little bit mysterious to me rook
a8 okay i guess it's
trying to force some action on the queen
side by
whites provoking a5 king b5 again would
be good for black
but white can just play the move knight
c5 keeping everything under control
now we see the move king to c6
and this is the moment when things i
think uh
start to to go a little bit crazy here
so
white for the moment seemingly has an
okay grip on the position
but it's sort of left in the balance
here where if white ever wants to make
use of this a pawn it comes at the price
of allowing the black king
to invade and that's sort of just too
hefty a price
to pay now we see the move though king
to d4
and this allows magnus again to shuffle
back to e8s
and after king dd3 magnus plays sort of
the uh
the craziest move of the game here so
who could come up with uh
some ways to continue the position with
black
in this case what can we do wasn't this
a blitz game i believe it was a
rapid game in the world cup i might be
wrong though
so a lot of people have magnus's move
and a couple people actually have what i
think is is the best move so
magnus came up with a rather crazy move
d4 which i'm
a little bit undersold on to be honest
with you
but i think the best move here is
actually the move uh f5
uh with the rook you want to open as
many files as possible
because at some point the white pieces
cannot control every single invasion
point we saw magnus open the e file for
this reason
and forcing the white king to make
concessions to stop rook to e2
but after f5 now white is in the very
very awkward spot
of having to open the g file which is
going to prove a much more difficult
file to keep closed and once again this
is only relevant because magnus
shoved this pawn onto h3 much much
earlier on
now h2 is a permanent weakness and if
the rook can just
invade we'll see some success for magnus
carlson
now why is this a better way than with
d4 well
if white were to play king takes d4 that
would be a pretty bad mistake and black
would just win
but white does have this move of knight
to b3
and the story is a lot more complex now
if you want to play something like rook
to e3 check you're running into king c4
don't even think about rook takes f3
because of knight takes d4 check
so instead we actually see the move king
d5 by magnus carlsen
and now white is actually able to
capture
on d4 this does come at a price though
with the move c5 temporarily forking
both pieces
but now knight b5 is threatening a
counter fork
so at the end of the day the dust
settles and we have
this position and this is where the the
real genius
of the end game comes to play so again i
believe this was a rapid game and magnus
perhaps messed up some of the tactics
there with the move d4
but now we have this position and i'm
not going to lie to you
now definitely white is better again
magnus was playing a very very
strong very good end game using the
threats against the h2 pawn to his
advantage
but he did miss the knockout blow with
f5 f5 would have led to a good position
for black
that was the correct way to invade here
though the tactics worked out in white's
favor
and the position is sort of deeply
simplified
so why is white better well black's only
past pawn is
now this pawn on c5 and moves like
f5 are coming with a lot less
a lot less threat now that the bishop
has successfully rerouted back to a more
defensive
square for example we could even do
something like g takes f5
g takes f5 and now white is quite
comfortably able to defend the weakness
on
h2 sort of without uh without hassle
so instead we see magnus player k8
hitting the pawn on a4
knight to c3 is simple enough now we're
d8 check king c2
and c4 so magnus pushing this pawn as
far up
as it will go we see knight to e2 rook
into d3
is pretty obvious you want to invade
with the rook whenever possible
highlighting white's weaknesses on the
king side
bishop out to c3 king to b7
and now knight to d4 and this is where
white has actually
let the advantage slip amazingly
the best way to keep the advantage is
with the crazy move
knight to g1 which looks a little bit
silly
at first putting the knight on g1 but at
the end of the day
magnus has made his own weakness by
pushing this pawn to h3
and is going to be a little bit hard
pressed to uh to justify having this
pawn here
with threats of knight takes h3 coming
and also threats of bishop takes f6
coming
so this would have been the way for
white to press the advantage
and it's going to be pretty tough here
for for black to continue
instead though we see knight d4 trying
to defend while activating the knight
centrally
now simply king to a6 is magnus
carlson's response and white has somehow
sort of
put all the pieces into jail because
none of them can really comfortably move
for those reasons we see white push to
a5 and now we finally see
f5 by black breaking things open for the
rook
g5 by white tries to keep things closed
and now we see once again magnus playing
f4 the most combative move
and this is the the takeaway that i want
you to uh
to have from this game if you learn
nothing else from this game
notice magnus's willingness to just
shove these pawns forward
uh leaving them undefended in order to
create weaknesses
for him to target with the rook on the
king's side
invading is no good if the rook isn't
able to uh to munch on some of these
pawns
so magnus ensures that the the rook
invasion is always threatening
by keeping these pawns weak if magnus
had instead played
some kind of passing move like king to
uh to b7
white could very seriously consider
playing a move like f4
and shoring up some of these weaknesses
right now
g6 is also going to be weak we no longer
have to worry about the pawn on f3
and once again on a very sunny day you
can imagine white
even somehow putting this bishop on g3
defending all the weaknesses and giving
the knight sort of free reign to roam
around
okay instead though f4 by magnus we see
king b2
by chaparnov kind of unable to move any
of the pieces
and now rook to d1 and magnus is uh
quite close to winning again with rook
h1 being an unstoppable threat
king a3 rick h1 bishop d2 take on h2
take on f4 and now rook d2
and magnus is close to winning
knight c6 played in the game and rook d3
check picks up another pawn
we see knight before check and uh
chaparranov is sort of all in on the a
pawn now
but it's not going to be enough it's
just not going to be enough magnus picks
up this pawn
we see king b7 king a6 and all the pawns
come tumbling down
you see h4 and this end game is
or sorry h2 rather and this end game is
pretty easily winning here
the king is just going to come in and
the rook has successfully stopped both
the king and the knight
from interfering with the pawn so it all
came crashing down
relatively quickly there with just one
mistake by chaparranov and again
the point i really wanted to highlight
in this game is magnus's first h5
h4 h3 and then even later f5 f4
shutting down white's mobility on the
king of side and locking in these
weaknesses
so that the rook invasions were
meaningful
and this just goes to show you the
difference between a player like magnus
carlsen
and players like myself and rochelle
blue magnus sort of
is able to balance all these things a
lot better and
actually get results out of them so
questions on this game before uh
we call it a night here on the uh the
youtube classes
questions here
um all right well i think i'm about
ready to call it a night then
on the end game class if you're watching
live please do join us
on twitch for another edition of analyze
your games
the class where i analyze your games
if you've had enough chess for the night
or if you're watching the the replay i
want to thank you very much for watching
as always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
[Music]
you